[Music]
good morning and welcome to the program
we start with breaking news and
conservative contender Matt Hancock has
withdrawn from the conservative
leadership contest he had the support of
19 of his fellow MPs yesterday let's go
live to Westminster we can talk to you
our political editor Beth Rigby Beth
there had been much anticipation about
whether or not mr. Hancock would pull
out being described as a vanity
candidate by Boris Johnson's campaign
team yes that's right there was talk
overnight about whether mr. Hancock
would withdraw quite simply because
there were three different candidates
quite closely linked in the campaign or
closely together that was Matt Hancock
Sajid Javid and Rory Stewart all getting
about the same number of votes mr.
Hancock
obviously understanding that perhaps he
wasn't going to get much further and
could get knocked out in the second
round so he's decided to withdraw from
the race I've just interviewed him he
wouldn't tell me who he was going to
switch allegiance to although I know mr.
Javid has been working hard on mr.
Hancock because I also interviewed mr.
Javid this morning who told me he wasn't
pulling out of the race
he wouldn't discuss a conversation he
had with mr. Hancock yesterday but he's
clearly behind the scenes trying to get
mr. Hancock to fall in with him the big
question is where do the votes of mr.
Hancock go next because that really
could affect who's in the final two who
goes up against mr. Johnson but in his
words this is the interview I just had
with him about why he's pulling out of
the race I think we can show that to you
now well I've been incredibly I've been
really pleased with the level of support
that I've received both from colleagues
and also outside Parliament and I also
feel like I've been making the arguments
that have been cutting through in this
race but it's quite clear that whilst
I've put myself forward as the candidate
of the future and focused on the future
and what we need to do after brexit that
the party is looking for somebody who's
more in the here and now and that means
I've decided to withdraw from the race
and I'm going to find the way to advance
the arguments and the values that I care
about that we should support free
enterprise and the free society that we
need to be open and outward looking an
optimistic as a party as a country and
I'll find I'll find other ways to to
advance those arguments now looked to
that and talked to all the candidates
before making a decision about who else
to support well you met with mr. subject
Javid yesterday didn't you and had a
private conversation are you going to
back such a Java doll you haven't
decided I'm going to make an
announcement about what next in the in
the coming days I've spoken to lots of
the different candidates and I can see
merit in lots of them you know
ultimately I put myself forward as the
candidate of the future I've been making
arguments about what the party needs to
be like the values we need to have the
policies we need to have the tone and
the way that we talk and how we need to
be in touch with modern Britain and
appealing to younger voters and and I'm
going to be looking to see which
candidates what the candidates say and
how best to advance these arguments
within the conservative party and
ultimately within the government and the
comeback but ultimately if you've got
mr. Johnson in the final two as the
here-and-now candidate as you put it the
other two in that bracket at the top are
mr. Gav and mr. hunt both here and now
candidates to you Sajid Javid Rory Co
you'll all the change candidates isn't
it that where your heart is in terms of
trying to get one of you three into the
final two and if it ain't going to be
you surely you would back mr. Javid or
are you going to go from Mr Gove because
you want another job in government well
I'm going to look at the I'm going to
talk to the candidates and I'm going to
work out what is the best way to advance
the values that I care about in in
government in the next government under
the next prime minister
so I'll be thinking about
over the weekend what about mr. Johnson
well as I say I'm going to talk to all
of the candidates and work out what is
the best way to advance the values that
I care about in the next conservative
government well you disappointed to come
in with 20 just ahead of Rory steward
did it mate you just think I've lost
momentum this is going to get
embarrassing if I carry on is that yeah
I did I did better than than we expected
and I was really pleased with the level
of support but it's also clear that you
know making the argument for being the
candidate for the future is just is not
where the party is at the moment and
that's understandable because of the
unique circumstances that we face
following that logic the other
candidates of the future mr. Stewart
then mr. Javid both with about the same
voice that you had done actually mr.
robb as well do you reckon they should
just sort of pull out and let the big
beasts fight it out well they'll make
their decisions what do you think well
I'm not going to put pressure on them
I'm going to think about what is the
best way for me to advance the values
that I care about that I've articulated
and made the case for in this campaign
and as I say I feel like I've been
winning arguments during the campaign
and you know trying to make the argument
that this contest needs to be as open as
possible I called for TV debates we're
now having TV debates I called for the
whole future of the Conservative
government to be more pro-business and
Pro enterprise and all the other
candidates are coming to that I I said
that we can't have four occation of
parliament as a way to get through
brexit and now increasingly the
candidates are saying that too and that
just on mr. Johnson he apparently has
privately told the ERG that he would be
open to perogy empowerment he certainly
hasn't publicly ruled that out is that a
red line for you in terms of backing him
well I think that prorogue in Parliament
is would be wrong it really again stall
the the democratic ideals that we stand
for as a country and also to be totally
impractical and it would never work so
that's a so I'm clear where I stand on
that and I want us to deliver brexit and
then move forward and it's the move
for word that I've been really focused
on just in terms of the race just one
more thing in terms of all of the
candidates wouldn't it be good to have
the future of the conservative party in
this race in the final two as well given
that mr. Johnson looks like he's
unassailable now wouldn't it be good to
have someone that isn't you know one of
the old faces of the party in the final
two that's where you're at well that's
the case that I've made and you know if
you look at the results of the first
round the party is it's pretty clear
that they want somebody who's involved
in the debates of the here-and-now now
I'm going to make I'm gonna focus on the
future and I'm going to concentrate on
making sure this party is always looking
with optimism to the future to deliver
for people because that's what we need
to do that's the whole point of being in
politics is to make life better for
people in this country and that's the
values I'm going to concentrate on